now to our uplift at eight where we
share stories that will bring some joy
to your day there are some skills you
are just born with for six-year-old
kashan Todd that's basketball check out
how he schools his dad right on their
living room Court
oh
that's one of his signature moves is
throwing the ball between his opponent's
leg he and his dad Quincy love showing
off their skills on social media they
have been practicing since kashan was
two years old let's see him use the
ceiling now
um playing basketball on this little
baby core and then I start when I grow
up and I played on the big corpse we
just hope to just keep inspiring people
to play the game basketball and and
ultimately uh to just have fun with the
process
the California do call themselves
hooplored and hoop Lord Jr Sean tells us
he wants to be a basketball player when
he grows up I mean here for
[Laughter]
here I know it's ready easy
Sean you ready